witnesses they came with photographs
hundreds and hundreds of photographs and
held them up for everyone to see it was
an act of courage and desperation to
what is the most difficult thing for you
[Music]
they're trying to find their relatives
daughters and grandchildren last seen in
Syria and Iraq which mujika my own at
the pustynia photograph here but they
know their loved ones may never return
for they are the wives and children of
jihadis are you still hopeful or are you
we didn't expect to see so many people
Russian women with a secret they've kept
hidden for years their daughters married
men who fought for Islamic state weeny
booties at the worst when he swam in the
Suez it's a lot what she heard a song
but the ocean credential Whitney boy
disaster they may fear the authorities
but they also need help and they've
asked Haider Sara Tova to assist them
but she's the only human rights activist
in Chechnya and she looked overwhelmed
yet another Kotori murdered by a factor
that is a break to our strategy yes the
booboo cleanly so often they appear way
to that by a harbor
the facts are hard to come by and this
group have few contacts in Iraq
instead they cling to old messages texts
and snaps the set of Euler path in
Arizona will on the switch at the gym
visit a masseur - Paris near Paducah
very key used in an ellipse Tyler mom -
peep show is privileged
40,000 people may have lost their lives
during the battle for Mosul and dead
bodies still lie under the rubble there
were survivors but those linked to is
have been put in special camps come on
you pretty stadium yeah but it's new
spit MS Enoch Ava says she understands
why her daughter went to Iraq Chechen
women have to follow their husbands she
says others like Fatima at a guy over
aren't so quick to forgive her daughter
Reseda
took four children to Syria but emotion
teeny Mangala scuzz that pastor answer
cata what reached it ago - two vodka
cotta was modern spam it was dope we
would receive to the breath this is Maya
provoking a bug where some feel shame
but everyone wants their loved ones back
a vigil kept in villages and mountain
valleys across the country and tired of
waiting people like pat amat Salomon OVA
have begun to organize to find their
voice she founded the group after her
daughter
Zelena went to Iraq most Nutella with
each 30 inch in the photos
it's turning my group O so that perfidy
logician in the wilderness the Boland
initiative earlier she has found some
comfort in their company and members of
her family offer love but Pat amat no
longer lives at home for every corner of
this place reminds her of her daughter's
absence cross the poster was for the
villain on this poster
when you told me your name Chester
Donovan yatza her mother's kept her
daughter's things her clothes and books
and toys but she hasn't had any news the
last time they spoke Selena said she was
trapped in Mosul the fighting all around
all hope rests with Hedda Saratoga it
seems the group has sent her names and
information and hundreds of videos this
one was taken in Mosul in 2015
images of three children forwarded by an
anxious grandmother
[Music]
families rarely mention their sons the
jihadis who left home to fight although
a woman did pass header images of her
son standing in a line of is prisoners
Lucia kirusha it's not the women at the
meeting talked about their sisters their
daughters their grandchildren in Iraq
but only one woman mentioned her son
why is that a beautiful most of us know
a master Mushin Nobita Boudicca Tori
Kelly okay Rosie paella kobato divide
you mirroring is really th how it is a
shame to wear their sympathy it's
generally reserved for the children of
jihadi families and the Chechen
government's lent a hand in the form of
several private jets it's flown 21
Russian youngsters back from Iraq still
miss Sara Tova says officials in the
nation's capital Moscow have done little
to help
in southern Russia 600 families have now
come forward and armed with photographs
and memories they are pleading for help
they used to whisper about their loved
ones but now they need to know John
sparks Sky News in Chechnya